- It is such an honor to have you here.
- My pleasure.
- Oh my god, I'm so stoked.
I was like, wait, what? Who's coming?
Like, it's the coolest
thing ever, to be a singer
and have this talk show, you
never thought you'd have.
And then get to meet all
these heroes that, you know,
I've been listening to,
still listen to, oh my gosh.
So, I'm gonna start with this,
Doja Cat, who I love,
just sampled, was it Walk On By?
- Walk On By.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Is that so cool?
You're like listening to the songs,
like, coming right back around.
- Yeah, it's amazing.
I didn't know that it
had been recorded by her
and my granddaughter called...
- Wait, they don't have to...
they have to ask
permission for that, right?
- No, not really.
(people laughing)
- That's a whole separate episode, okay.
- Yeah, they sample it, and it's theirs.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- But anyway, my granddaughter called me.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And asked, Grammy, I say yeah,
do you know you're on
a record with Doja Cat?
I said, Doja who?
(people laughing)
She said, she's a rapper and she's a...
and she went into explaining
all of this to me.
And I said, okay, and what
song are we talking about?
She said, Walk On By,
completely through the entire song.
Okay.
Well apparently it's a major hit for her.
- Oh, no, no, it's huge,
Paint The Town Red, yeah.
(people laughing)
It's a solid hit that.
- I'm thrilled for that, and like I said,
when I heard that it had been done,
I hope Walk On By is as good for her
as it has been for me.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It's wonderful.
- I think what's cool about
it too is like people...
I'm sorry, you can clap, you
were clapping, I'm sorry.
(audience clapping)
I think what's interesting
too, is, you know,
I grew up on that song.
I love a lot of Burt Bacharach,
obviously, a partner of yours,
that you worked with a lot.
But, I just think it's cool
because you introduce people like a whole
different generation.
- Yeah.
- To songs that they might not have known.
- Absolutely. And they're great songs.
And finally they're being
exposed to, good music.
Thank Jesus.
- Yeah, Amen, yes, yes.
(audience clapping)
So, I have to ask, I didn't know this,
but, you're kind of, the
breakout moment for you
in your career was, it was the first night
that you were at Apollo, right?
- Yeah, we did, I did
the, it was a Gospel Show
and my group, The Gospelaires,
up here on amateur night.
And, it was really
weird, because we decided
to sing a song called It Goes That Wait.
It was recorded by a
group out of Philadelphia.
The Imperials.
And we were appearing on the Gospel Show,
and we had no idea that they were standing
in the wings while we sang their song.
- Oh, were you happy, you didn't know?
- Yes, quite happy, believe me.
But, they were so kind to us.
You did a wonderful job,
we're thrilled about you
singing our song,
and as it turned out, we won.
- Oh my gosh.
Well, people knew then,
but I think what's even cooler
is I heard afterwards you,
they were like, hey, we're looking
for some singers to be on this record.
And then you ended up in
the studio right after that.
- Yep, sure did.
Our group went to New York, New Jersey.
The A Team.
(people laughing)
at the Boy Records,
and we did our very
first background session.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- For Sam "The Man" Taylor
and Nappy Brown.
- [Kelly] Wow.
- And that was our introduction to singing
the 'oohs' and 'ahs'
and the "yeah, yeah's"
that you hear on the recordings.
- Yeah, I just think it's
a lesson too, to say Yes.
because you were like, you
didn't even, you all...
I heard that you didn't even know what
you all were saying yes to, really.
- Yeah, we didn't even
know what a background was.
(people laughing)
- You're just like, we'll do it.
I love that, because you never
know what experience will come from that.
You also had to, this,
I find this incredible
because it just seems so long ago,
but it's actually not that long ago.
But you toured during segregation.
- Like, how incredibly difficult was that?
- It was interesting, to put it mildly.
Something I'd never experienced before.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But it was a case of, it was,
it became an adventure for me.
I'm one of those real
rebels, real ones, that's me.
- Yeah.
- And, I had never experienced
anything that said,
oh, you can't sit here
or you can't go there,
or you can't drink this, or you can't...
- Can't sing this song.
- Excuse me...
What you mean I can't?
No, of course, that doesn't
exist in my vocabulary.
- Yeah, it's almost like when
they tell you that, it's like,
well, you've now made it a red button
that I will be pressing.
- Will be pressing.
- Yeah.
- Several times.
- Yeah, I heard that one
time that you, the club
or somewhere, where you
were performing said
they didn't want you to
perform a certain song
and you're like, that's in
my set, I'm going to sing it.
And then you all had to get off the stage.
They ended up...
- Yeah, they closed the Show down.
It was Ray Charles, What'd I Say,
and there's a verse in there
that I changed a little of.
"tell your mama, tell
you Pa and I'm gonna..."
the words is "I'm gonna
send you back to Arkansas"
But I said, I'm gonna segregate,
I'm gonna integrate Arkansas.
And they said, oh, you can't say that.
Yes, I can.
- [Kelly] Watch me.
(people laughing)
- I can, and I did.
- I love that.
- And they shut the Show down
(audience clapping)
- It's important
- So, I found this information out
and I was certain in my soul
that you had already been honored
at the Kennedy Center Honors.
It's like in my mind when
I heard that, oh my gosh,
you're gonna be honored at
the Kennedy Center Honors.
I was like, that hadn't already happened.
Like, for me in my brain
that had already existed.
- You and so many others, they thought
I had already been honored.
As a matter of fact,
even the Kennedy Honors
thought I had been honored.
(audience laughing)
- I know, I, whenever
it happened, I was like,
this has not happened yet.
What's wrong with us, as a race.
I don't understand the
human race right now.
But I mean, you've worked
with, first of all,
congratulations on that.
(audience cheering)
That's incredible.
I think it's over due, but
I think it's incredible.
- Yes it is.
- Yeah, well you have worked with
and influenced so many
artists in your career,
so we wanted to talk about a few.
because there's so many amazing ones.
So we're gonna start with
Elvis, which I just find
so random and awesome.
I heard a story that was
really cool about this man
with you, but I wanna make sure it's real.
And it involved him
like signing some stuff.
- Yeah.
- That happened, it's
real, tell them, okay.
- I was opening at the Sands Hotel
and he was opening at the,
well, at the Continental at the time.
And I went over to see my
Aunt Sissy, who was a part
of The Sweet Inspirations,
who were backing him up on the show.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And, was introduced to him
and he was such a nice man.
Oh, and he's so pretty.
(audience laughing)
He really was, but he was so kind.
And he says, oh, you're opening tonight.
I said, yeah, he says, I
am too, I said, I know.
He said, well, when you go
to your news record store,
you're gonna find a surprise from me.
I'm going to give you a gift.
I said, okay.
And in every single one of my albums,
he has signed an autograph
photograph and stuck it inside.
And he made the announcement
from the stage, his stage,
that if you buy a Dionne Warwick CD
or what they call CDs
now, it was an album.
- An album, yeah.
- If you buy one, you'll
find a surprise inside of it.
And it was a photograph of him.
- That is so cool.
- Yeah.
- I mean, just that an
artist goes out their way
to support another artist.
- I know.
- That's incredible, there's
so many cool things about that.
I bet sales were well.
(audience laughing)
- You tell me.
- I was like, I bet they ran.
They were like, and later.
Okay, so I heard this story too,
which I just,
you are so gangster.
So I heard that you
called, is it Snoop Dogg
and Suge Knight to your
house for a meeting?
- Yes.
- Please tell everyone the story,
(audience laughing)
because you were listening to,
and this is probably the age they were
so wait, so you were listening
to a song with your son?
- With my son.
- Okay.
- Yes, as it turns out,
Damon, was in the car with me
and this rap thing came on.
Ugh...
(audience laughing)
And he was saying
every single word of it.
And I turned the radio off and said,
how do you know every
single word of this song?
He said, oh, that's rap.
I said, yeah, okay.
I said, do you know the
Declaration of Independence?
Ah, no.
- Silent.
(people laughing)
- I said, well, I'll tell you what,
until you learn every single word of the
Declaration of Independence
and you say it to me
- Rehearse it, yeah.
- You will not listen
to this kind of music.
Oh mommy.
Yeah, oh mommy is right.
- But then you called them to your house.
- Yeah, I called them to
the house based on the fact
that they were all using,
kind of not such nice words.
- Yeah, especially towards women.
- And you know, I kind of,
and I was one of the very
first ones to combat them
with what they were
saying, misogynistic words,
calling young ladies
out the name, you know.
I said, how many young
ladies do you see walking
around on four legs with a tail,
you know, and calling them out the names.
(audience laughing)
(audience clapping)
- I love it.
- Yes well, I made it my
business to let them know that
you made me part of the problem.
Now I want you to make
me part of the solution.
- Yeah.
I'll tell you what,
I actually had the opportunity
to work with Snoop, as well,
and you must have made an impact.
because he's so respectful.
He's like, so great to work with.
- He's wonderful now.
Like I told him, I said,
you are all gonna grow up.
You're gonna meet somebody
that you're gonna fall in love with.
And of course, "no, no, no"
you know "yeah, yeah, yeah".
And you're gonna get married,
you're gonna have children
and one of those children is gonna be
the young lady, a little girl.
And eventually that little
girl's going to hear what you
recorded and she's gonna look
at you and she's gonna ask
you, daddy, did you really say that?
- Yeah, I get in to
trouble for saying, damn,
my kids will call me up for saying damn.
- That's right, yeah.
- Yeah,
can you imagine the
hell they're gonna get?
- Oh yeah.
(people laughing)
Exactly, but it happened.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You know, and he, still
to the day, thanks me.
- Yeah, he's so cool, I love him.
He's fun to work with, you
never know what's gonna happen.